let's talk about the Internet the
Internet is a dreary garbage strewn
wasteland populated by barely sentient
trolls and zombies the Internet is a
portal into the darkest foul lists most
disgusting recesses of the human soul
the Internet is I'm convinced a blight
on mankind the Internet is certainly a
net negative for the human race there
are some positive aspects to it but the
positive aspects are so vastly
outweighed by the negative that it's
almost embarrassing to bring up the
positives at this point it's
embarrassing to look at all of the
destruction this thing is a rot on
mankind and to say well yeah but it
helps me stay in touch with my friends
and family and yes I say this as a
person on the Internet
who uses the internet to make a living
I'm using this internet the Internet to
send this message that is anti Internet
and I am a person who makes a living on
the Internet
I understand all that ok I understand
the irony you may even call me a
hypocrite
maybe I am a hypocrite I hope I'm not
I'm not trying to be that's not my point
here but if that's the accusation you
want to lob against me you're free to do
that what I've tried to do personally is
is I have tried to take this thing this
awful monstrous thing and use it to
speak some truth because I I noticed
that although there's quite a lot being
said on the internet and shouted back
and forth does not appear to be a lot of
truth
a lot of real truth anyway there's there
are a lot of people who are out there
saying I'm speaking truth I don't care
what anyone thinks I'm just gonna tell
it like it is there are a lot of people
on the internet who have that brand
but what I noticed and what I noticed
before I started doing this is that the
vast majority of them are actually just
saying they're all they're doing is
pandering what they're saying is a
careful calculation because they know
that there's going to be a wide audience
of people that line up to Pat them on
the back for saying this supposedly
controversial thing and so I noticed
that and I said well
maybe I should get on here and try to
say some things that that that perhaps
most people actually will not say
that's been my mission and what I feel
called to do
that I've had some success in that
regard
that's up to you to decide
but what I can say is that it's and so
I'm not I'm not going anywhere even
though I'm saying all this I still feel
as low as long as God has given me this
platform in platforms platforms
go away everything nothing lasts on the
internet especially platforms
somebody can have an audience in a
platform one day in the next day it's
gone everything just goes away like that
and if and when that happens to me I'm
not gonna cry about it I won't weep over
it it's God's will but right now it
seems that it's God's will that I have
this platform and I use it to say things
and so that's what I'm doing but it is
hard to make any kind of a lasting
impression to say anything meaningful on
the Internet is hard becomes and it's
becoming harder and harder and harder
because there are billions of people all
shouting into the same void and even to
have an audience online these days is no
longer any kind of novelty it's it's not
a big deal when I first started doing
this five years ago or so it seemed like
there was a relatively small community
of what whatever we are whatever we were
I don't know Internet personalities I
whatever you want to call it there was a
small community it seemed like of people
who had any kind of real platform and
audience now though only five six years
later it's like everybody has an online
audience everybody has a brand there's
not a big deal anymore it's not novel
and it seems every day I'm scrolling
through Facebook and I come across some
new random dude or woman
shouting into a webcam and saying
things that are meaningless and
pointless and Hollow
regurgitating talking points taking
these rehashed regurgitated microwaved
talking points and feeding them to the
audience some more because it would seem
like there are quite a lot of people on
the internet who have an insatiable
appetite for talking points even if
they've heard those exact talking points
a million times they want to hear they
want to they want to hear him a million
more times and so it seems every day
there's another person who becomes an
internet sensation by
saying the same thing that everybody
else is saying and so I'll see some new
random guy you know you know because I'm
curious and so I look at their Facebook
page and I'll see that oh they have oh
this person has a million and a half
followers and I think what that guy
really a million and a half people he
warrants a million and a half and a half
people listening to him
I'm sure many people have had the same
thought about me I realized that so
these content creators and that's and
that's really what people who make a
living on the Internet
what we're call we are content creators
and that's really an apt name because
for most of us that's all we're
interested in doing it's not necessarily
saying anything that means anything
um we're not not worried about not
worried about substance not worried
about quality not worried about being
meaningful but simply we're worrying
about pushing out content it's just
stuff for you to click here click this
click this click this here's some more
stuff to click click this thing click
this thing click this thing watch this
thing ok stop watching that watch this
watch this watch this watch that look at
this look at this look at this look at
that
that's what content creators are doing
for the most part it doesn't matter what
the thing is anything if I can get you
to click on anything I don't care what
it is just click on it
it's like imagine if you were at
7-eleven or something and you went to
the refrigerated section where all the
bottled bottled drinks are and you saw
saw a bottle some nondescript bottle and
with some weird substance inside some
off-colored off colored substance and on
the label it just said content okay
whoever made this bottle of whatever it
is they don't even care what's in the
bottle it's just it's stuff it's it's a
substance it is content it is filled
with something now here drink it now of
course you would never pick up that
bottle and drink it but on the internet
you do it all the time on the internet
all the time you are consuming content
simply because it is content and the
content creators then are quite happy
that the average American spends 25
hours a week online in addition to its
35 hours a week of TV so that's 60 hours
a week all told and that's a low
estimate 25 hours a week online I know
you're thinking the same thing that I
thought when I saw that statistic that
sounds pretty low but remember this is
average for all Americans so 25 hours a
week that number is is brought down
considerably by the 65 and over crowd
who certainly are on the internet now
more than they would have been even five
years ago but the grand grandparents and
great-grandparents are bringing that
average down I think if we were to look
at average time spent on the internet
for people between the ages of 13 and
say 45 or 50 that numbers gonna go way
up but on average we're talking 35 hours
a week watching TV 25 hours a week
online at 60 hours staring at screens
every almost every waking moment now as
human beings we spend staring at screens
and that is not even though I need you
to stare at screens so that I can make a
living and feed my family I am telling
you stop doing it stop living your life
this way it helps me okay it it's to my
advantage so that there's there is no I
could have no ulterior motive and
telling you to stop doing it but I'm
telling you to stop doing it because
it's destroying you it's destroying all
of us this is not a life okay this is
not a human existence a life spent doing
this with your phone just
okay this is this is what life has
become just this
this is your whole life but for a lot of
people your whole life is just this
just that staring at this and this
motion and that's all that's life but
that's not life that's not a life that's
not a human life the human life is lived
outside in three dimensions interacting
with people and with things and with
nature and that's what life is supposed
to be and we know for teenagers it's
even worse what kind of people what kind
of people are we raising teenagers
statistically at this point basically
never look up from their phones
we're talking nine to ten hours a day
ten hours a day on average teenagers are
spending consuming media ten hours a day
again I say that is not a human
existence we all have the same stories
and so this is a familiar complaint but
it's an important complaint and one that
we need to deal with and we're not and
that is you know if you're ever around
and this everyone is like this nowadays
but teenager its it for teenagers it's
even worse because this has been their
life since they were babies and they've
literally been raised on the internet
and at this point I think it's almost
like a physical dependency has has been
formed
but we've all been around teenagers and
and they I wrote this forget what I
wrote a few months ago but I relayed
this story from last year when my family
we went to a family reunion on my wife's
side of the family in Minnesota we're at
a lake house and so multiple generations
of the family all at this lake house and
there's a jet ski and there's fishing
and there's it's it's great right and
I'm having a blast I'm with my
brother-in-law we're fishing we're all
taking turns on the jet ski we're going
on the pontoon
we're having a great time I put my phone
away I had it off for probably four or
five days I didn't even look at it it
was I loved it I just loved not it I
took vacation day so I didn't have to
and I was completely out of the loop I
was oblivious and I was loving
but the younger generation there at the
family reunion the teenagers
the 10 the really 10 to 20 crowd they
don't look up from their phone you
entire time we could be out on the
pontoon there looking at their phone we
could be playing cards at night they're
looking at their phone they're looking
at the phone they do not look up from
ever
again I say this is not this is not
human this is really bad guys it really
is I know everyone complains about it
like I said but this is really bad
I know I don't even think we understand
yet we cannot even comprehend the
consequences
of raising a generation like this it
truly is unlike anything that the world
has ever seen
yeah every generation has their new
technology every you know every era of I
should say every era of human society
has some new technological advancement
and yeah there are always people who are
concerned about what that technological
advancement will do
but this is different this is life being
condensed down to this
and you know one other thing about that
when we talk about anytime somebody
starts wringing their hands over the
internet you're always gonna have the
people who say yeah but you know people
did that with cars everyone worried that
cars we're gonna destroy society
everyone worried that TVs would destroy
society everyone would worried that
phones would destroy society and society
turned out fine didn't it
and every time I hear that I always
think
did society turn out fine are you so
sure that those people issuing those
prophetic warnings about cars and TVs
and everything were they really wrong
I don't think they were totally wrong
now I'm not saying that it that I you
know we should all give up our cars or
that necessarily the world would be
better without cars but actually even
something like the automobile has had a
has had some positive effects but it has
had some very serious detrimental
effects to society that some people
early on saw and and knew that was gonna
happen and they warned us and their
warnings actually came true and yet here
we are looking at them and say see how
wrong they were they weren't wrong they
were right there were people with cars
so for instance warned that okay now
that we have cars we the ability to go
anywhere we want what you're gonna find
is that the family's gonna break apart
people are gonna spread far apart
they're gonna spread far away from their
families they're gonna spread far away
from their jobs the children are gonna
leave their parents and be far away it's
gonna lead to the breakdown of the
family or even people that warn that
with cars you know people aren't gonna
be going to church as often because now
the kids are gonna be getting the cars
and going off and doing something else
rather than going to church these were
the things people warning about and it
did actually happen so with the internet
and of course there are people with the
TV who warned the TVs gonna take over
our life it's gonna it is going to
undermine the family and now the entire
fam the existence of the family is going
to be centered around the TV there were
people warning about that in the 30s 40s
and 50s and they were right that is what
happened
I don't know about 30s when did it when
was a TV event I don't know
so with the internet I think there are a
lot of warnings being issued that are
that are correct that are right
you
and this is to say nothing of all the of
all the porn you know I've talked about
all the things problems with point with
with the Internet
probably the biggest problem is that it
has turned us into a race of people who
are completely obsessed with pornography
and don't give me that well there used
to be Playboy magazine
okay yeah there was Playboy magazine and
even that is pretty recent
but you didn't have
billions of people across the world who
were spending hours and hours and hours
of their week reading Playboy magazine
you do have that with the Internet to be
precise and this is just on one website
pornhub porn hub they released their
statistics at the end of every year how
long how much time do people spend
watching videos on just their platform
and right now we're at the point where
on average humanity spends
four-and-a-half billion hours watching
porn on just that site
that's 500,000 years worth of porn in
one year
that means that over the next decade
humanity will spend five million years
collectively watching porn and a sizable
portion of that audience will be
children that wasn't happening with
Playboy magazine the Playboy under your
dad's mattress which is the stereotype
people weren't spending four billion
hours looking at Playboy
it's different
and it has had an effect on us studies
show Americans between the porn and
everything else we do online Americans
our memory has suffered our attention
spans have suffered we can't remember
anything we can't pay attention to
anything we need constant stimulation we
can't stay focused on one thing at a
time we can't interact with other human
beings our written language has
deteriorated and you can see that you
can see how our our language is kind of
plummeted back into the Stone Age and
now we're using hieroglyphics again but
we call them emojis and you have all
these people can't communicate can't
convey an emotion through the written
language without using a smiley face or
a frowny face me happy me sad look at
smiley face that's what you have college
educated literate supposedly intelligent
people who cannot communicate happiness
sadness whatever through sentences so
they have to use pictures
I truly believe that
your life will be so much better if you
cut out the Internet
or at least you cut down on it
drastically
drastically and I think you would become
a much happier more fulfilled more
serious more intelligent person
you you would lose nothing I would lose
something if you cut down on the
internet I would lose your clicks your
traffic your attention and the money
that comes with it
but I'm willing to lose that if it means
that more and more people are starting
to live human lives again
and then you free up time once you start
taking once you start reclaiming your
life and detaching yourself from the
phone and from the internet from TV then
you free up time to do other things like
to play with your kids or read books or
do anything else III don't know train
for a marathon become a beekeeper learn
how to learn how to garden learn I just
anything
pick a subject and become an expert in
it and not because you googled it you
look at Wikipedia you watch the YouTube
video but become a real expert just pick
a subject whether it's a historical
subject or or anything it's a scientific
subject literature history or art you
know any any subject at all pick a
subject and become an expert say to
yourself I'm gonna read 15 books on this
subject over the next year and I'm gonna
know it
why not that's how we become interesting
people that's how we become interesting
substantive people when we know things
and we have real interests Facebook is
not an interest YouTube is not an
interest
you
it's where we go when we have no
interests
so what would you be missing if you cut
your 25 hours a week down to say 5 or 1
5 hours I think is a good why not that
let's let's do 5 hours a week that's one
hour a day Monday through Friday which
is still kind of a lot but and then no
hours on the weekend so you have your
weekend entirely free of that and I
think that's great that's moderation
that would be fantastic
there'll be a great start wouldn't
but I think this process of reclaiming
our lives from the internet it's you
have to do it one piece at a time I
think if you want to break a habit you
got to break it into pieces first and
then you can break the habit and so
let's let's focus on I think if we're
gonna work on this together
focus on it one piece at a time
so let's start here you got to start
somewhere but at least you what do we
just start with this start with the
morning
take the internet out of your morning
no I don't know about you but I have and
I I wrote about this a few weeks ago and
since then I've been trying to correct
it
not totally successfully but I in the
past had developed a very bad habit and
I know that statistically this is what
most people do at least between the ages
of 18 and 44 most people are just like
me in this regard the first thing I do
when I wake up in the morning is I look
at my phone I have my alarm which is on
my phone so I pick up my phone turn off
the alarm
well actually I hit snooze on the alarm
and then put it back and then I hit
snooze again and put it back then I hit
snooze again and now finally when I'm
ready you actually get up now but I
don't just put the phone down because
now I have the phone in my hand and so I
it's very easy to just turn off the
alarm and then just click on one more
thing and now here I am in cyberspace
and that's how I start my day on the
Internet um at least up until recent
first thing I do is I look at my email I
look at my personal emails I see all the
spam and the junk and all the stuff but
I look at my work email and then for me
I look at my public emails which are
emails from readers and fans and people
who hate me and all that and and so
that's great for some reason I've felt
the need just begin my day looking at
that kind of stuff and which means
invariably there's gonna be at least one
message overnight that'll say you know
something like Matt you're a piece of
garbage and I hope you die and then okay
great I'm glad that I could start I'm
glad that I read that and I know that
about and so now I can start my day that
little little little dose of
self-loathing to start the day it's
great but then the next thing I do is
I'd scan the headlines then I would
check social media as this whole process
starting the day and all of that would
take about five minutes you know how it
is with the Internet's
even though it's even though I'm
checking five or six different things do
it in five minutes a nice concentrated
little shot of anxiety and vitriol to
start the day with
and I I think it's just toxic
it is a it is a toxic awful way to begin
your day
so if we're going to cut down
drastically on our internet and media
usage I think maybe we begin here
because consider also most people they
check their phone first thing in the
morning like I do they also that their
phones the last thing they're looking at
at night before they go to bed and there
are even I read apparently there are
people who are so addicted to the
Internet that their brain wakes them up
in the middle of the night so they can
check social media so there are people
who they check the there they're
checking the phone before they go to bed
they're waking up to check it and then
they go back to sleep and they wake up
three hours later and then they check
their phone again and then they go
downstairs for breakfast and they're on
their phone again and they never put
down their phone so what if we all
pledged
it's a it's a modest way to begin here
and goal of detaching ourselves from the
internet and not being dependent on it
what have we begin by making a pledge
and we say to ourselves we're not going
to look at our phones in bed that's it
naca borrowing an emergency and somebody
calls and there's been some terrible
thing that happened overnight or
whatever
barring emergency we are not going to
look at our phones in bed
period
not gonna look
and even though it's only a
comparatively small amount of your day
that you spend in bed before going to
sleep and after waking up it's still
think about you free up that time
you sever it from the internet
and what can you do at that time now
there's this nice little chunk of time
it's an important time too because it's
the time right at the beginning the day
and run at the end and so this decides
how do you start and how do you end so
it's important time it's precious time
what are you gonna do at that time now
you're free it's like oh I'm free I
don't have to worry about Facebook or
Twitter what are you gonna do at that
time you could read a devotional you
could read the Bible you could pray it's
just anything you could do anything you
know another thing you could do with
that time you could do and this is great
and I think we've lost this in modern
society it's maybe one of the worst
things about the Internet is that we've
lost this we've lost the ability to do
nothing
what if you took that extra time
you did nothing with it
nothing
you have simply silence and stillness
and nothing
maybe you lay there and you look at the
ceiling and you think you form thoughts
you contemplate
that's how we become
real thinking substantive people is when
we have time to think and I think this
is we know that the Internet has
intruded on our social lives and changed
the way that we interact it's changed
kind of our exterior lives in a big way
and mostly in a harmful way but even
worse than that is that the Internet has
taken over our interior lives in that we
don't think anymore because any extra
time that we have where there's nothing
going on you're waiting in line your
whatever
I was at I was I was in a waiting room
recently I don't forget what I think it
was as I said the dentist in a waiting
room and there was a bunch of people all
sitting around and of course every
single one myself included we were all
just staring at our phone because the
idea of sitting there for 30 minutes and
maybe talking to the person next to you
or saying nothing and just sitting there
we can't even conceive anymore of the
idea of simply sitting somewhere and
doing nothing but that's up until the
internet and phones came along I was a
very common thing for human beings you
had you had plenty of moments like that
where you were sitting and not really
doing anything those are important
moments because that's when you live
within yourself and we need to have that
but we've lost that now
think the internet does our thinking for
us the internet literally completes our
sentences for us
and now we can instead of forming a full
thought we can follow a half-formed
thought train of thought all across the
Internet
and people we know over sharing online
rather than having thoughts they keep
inside themselves thoughts that they
otherwise would have kept inside
themselves and should have kept inside
themselves now we can spill it all out
on the Internet
get it out there
so maybe you do that with your time
just a suggestion
but I think this could be a good place
to begin
so maybe we can make that pledge
together
I think we'll all be happier for it
and if I get a few less of your clicks
and your views maybe because that's the
time you spend when you read something
that I wrote or you watch a video of
mine
that's fine I'll make that sacrifice
because I think it's better for you it's
better for all of us
well thanks for watching thanks for
listening to this on the Internet
Godspeed everybody